oh sorry tanya to interrupt but but look
at this magnus played ac move i mean
okay
this is not this is not a mouse slip
peter this is not the most if it's
intentional you know like i bounce back
it's one one and now i'm gonna play hd
and and we take it from there i mean
okay i i really did not want to but i
felt like after ac
we have to talk about this
but you know we've seen magnus do this
throughout the tournament especially in
these uh online events we've seen him
play f3 we've seen him play well now a3
we've seen him play all these new
openings that he's coming up with and
very often it puts the pressure on the
opponent that you need to show me
something because otherwise it's a bit
uncomfortable to face this stuff yeah
exactly and you remember there was a
there was a question after young won the
candidates and it was not yet clear what
will be magnus's choice
that uh what is your kind of advice or
what do you say to magnus and then i
believe jan was saying yeah